this dash cam video captured the moment
the bombs hit
striking a residential neighborhood in
this north ukrainian city
witnesses said the targets included
apartment buildings and a hospital more
than 30 people were killed
this nearby school was also hit by one
of around 500 rockets american officials
say russia has fired over the past week
they can hit anywhere and there is no
location here
which where you can feel safe this
security analyst lives in ukraine's
second largest city she recorded these
videos and told global news they've lost
electricity and are running out of food
there is no possibility to leave the
city in a safe manner because
the the whole city is under the constant
bombardment but she and other civilians
may soon have a chance to escape
ukrainian officials met their russian
counterparts for a second day of
negotiations and agreed to create
humanitarian corridors for civilians to
get out and aid to get in
the ukrainian president called on
vladimir putin to meet with him to
negotiate an end to the invasion
russia's missile and bomb strikes are a
confession that they have failed to do
anything substantial on our soil he said
but others don't share that optimism
explosions heard from kiev are growing
louder as the russian military inches
closer to the ukrainian capital
the russian president told his security
council the military operation is going
according to plan the next 24 to 96
hours are going to be very telling
about really the emerging russian
strategy
about 90 percent of the russian forces
that had massed around ukraine are now
reportedly inside the country if the
ukrainian resistance stiffens
this is going to get extraordinarily
bloody and we're talking thousands if
not tens of thousands of casualties jeff
semple global news